no it's already happening i don't want
to trade left the station i don't want
to do this it's left the station i don't
want it
[Music]
america on the edge and frank head white
privilege gavin newsom ronda santos new
york gun control biden family dirty
felons nancy has some bagel melon saudi
fist bum falling stocks outbreak of
monkey
pox in japan touchy feely vince mcmahon
fauci covet times two trudeau penis
hairdo paulie walnuts r.i.p there's no
cuffs on aoc oil to china price of gas
affleck mary's giant
[Music]
very normal stopping hearts j6 hearing
no one view netflix not renewed
bo joe big disgrace james what picks
from outer space dr jill calls me a food
leah thomas still a dude joseph fighting
liver spots got coveted after four shots
al gore go to hell trying to cancel dave
chappelle you're a transphobic
pedophiler kitty didler now he can't
just be invited
[Music]
[Music]
goes on and on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
oh that's the sound
of we're back hold on i still have to
adjust my headphones one last time
because we're here for the first time do
you hear to my voice you guys hear my
voice we were getting ready to come back
and then uh covet
what yeah but i had one positive and one
negative so i'm just gonna count it as a
negative that cancels it out yeah it
cancels it out uh i am so glad to be
back with you we have so much to get to
uh we just covered everything that we
missed so don't ask us to
the cliff's notes four years in a row
um a lot of developments here uh at
atlanta with crowder we're actually
tomorrow love thomas and i can show you
what's been going on in the office and
the studios and what we've been
rebuilding
look before we go on please hit the like
button
leave a comment
share we try not to do that every single
show right off the top because people do
it and it becomes white noise but for
future reference that's the best thing
you can do to help with the algorithm
which of course tells the rest of
youtube that we do not exist so
uh today we'll be talking about uh the
recession
it's not no no not at all and uh britain
arresting a veteran by the way for
causing anxiety on social media and uh
drag queen uh stories that are uh well
stories drag queen shows that are
happening in churches
particularly the episcopal church or as
i call it not a church not a church not
a church
[Laughter]
so before i move on my question to you
of the days what is the biggest impact
what are you feeling from this not
recession
by that i mean redefined
and by that i mean shut up and take it
shut up and take it how this guy gives
it to you okay we're gonna move on we
have gerald a in studio how are you i'm
well you're doing okay i'm doing fine
honestly tested the coved tested
negative and today i feel fine so it was
about day and a half are you gonna take
another test no why would you i don't
want the government monitoring i feel
like cvs sends it back to the government
so yeah check this guy out it's monkey
pox isn't it and then we have of course
you know him you love him he is here the
quickest man on his feet mr landau dave
ahoy how are you i'm fine we are going
to be on tour together dave landau and i
you can go to lotto crowd.com tour for
the rebels of the cause tour we're going
to be in phoenix september 16th the
arizona smart fight the arizona
financial center houston september 17th
smart financial center a lot of
financial centers a lot of smart too
they don't they leave no pot without
their hand in it and then charleston
west virginia on october 8th it's not a
recession so everything's being changed
to financially yes exactly that's the
deal yes exactly paid for by your tax
dollars indeed these banks they're
looking out for you
uh still no word on the credit union
center no none
or the pay cash center
the no debt center johnny monero's uh
loan sharks no
no western union center maybe there is i
have no idea yeah probably in the bronx
station next to some bombed out building
um by the way too i want to so some
announcements okay
coming out here this fall can have a
children's book
coming out this fall change my mind book
here sometime soon not by the fall but
we will have a children's book
the first week of september last week of
august
is parody week because you guys have
been asking for more of these so each
morning
the intro is going to be an all new
parody takes a lot of time to work on we
worked on those during the break that's
august 29th through september
1st yeah and we'll be announcing some
new shows that we'll be producing here
at with credit studios
what
moving and shaking moving and shaking
like a drag queen reverend no
priest
no pastor
well card's correct in some ways that
could be better yeah in some ways you
never know in some ways it could be the
same yeah kind of not all that different
no
just go to the beach house and you'll
find it okay before all of that uh this
happened new york commuters got more
than they bargained for during their uh
rush hour commute this comes from new
york post
oh my god i hope someone laid down some
rocks
[Music]
so it's just the subway with tarps
[Music]
now i would check my white privilege but
uh
we get in trouble when we do a change my
mind if we're moderately blocking the
sidewalk
what happens there if i can't get off i
couldn't i missed my stop on the l train
why because of a giant oily ass
yeah i slipped in a bunch of it yes
cracked my head on a bowl yeah new
york's going to masks again yeah yeah
yeah math that's the problem yeah
well i guess she was wearing one i
wonder if ky jelly though does wipe down
those bowls yeah they are filthy it
could be who do you think that was
sponsored by dave oh that's a good point
yeah that's what they're going to be
competing with astroglide this is all
another ploy of big astroglide folks
honestly uh after living in new york for
three years that's hardly the worst
thing i've seen yeah
i take that train over most of them it's
hardly the worst thing that's happened
to me on the subway at least that's a
woman yeah that's true at least you
could survive and get off the subway
when i used to take the subway i'd have
to dress like paddington bear you know
that several of them took the baby pools
home oh yes
absolutely still need this for my nine
kids
don't be mad at the slip and slide it's
gone so just you know what the best
thing is if you guys are watching
because we have we have a you know
multi-faceted viewership uh put that
slip and slide on the third rail that's
true that's the end did anyone get
arrested can someone follow up maybe in
the control room please tell me somebody
got arrested for that
remember when we got we got pulled aside
by the cops for a change my mind like
you can't have that uh you can't have
that tripod here on the sidewalk it's
blocking traffic it's not even a tripod
it's a monopod it's one stick
it's one step with the camera through
the pod and i'm standing we can't allow
you to do this uh there are people who
need to uh ass clap uh coming in here
yes please set up that slip and slide
right there a m is proud to have you yes
uh do you have permits for the spearmint
rhino you set up in car three no no no
no no
no no they just have pure they just have
a permit for the actual rhino yes yes
are you allowed to drink on the shelves
i'm sorry anything but spearmint yes
i want a spearmint rhino for christmas i
really don't
all right
so
and by the way we have some new some of
you are saying no we actually did
upgrade the studio in quite a few ways
you just may not necessarily see them
yet we've had to move things over but i
like the way the old studio looks so you
know we've kept the look and just
migrated some things and added some
enhancements that you'll see um all
right
here's my question to you uh before we
move on we're gonna talk about biden and
this administration redefining the
recession this all happened while i was
gone
and i came back and there was a lot of
me catching up on news you know kind of
being
briefed yeah even though i stay in the
loop but i do try and mentally
disconnect a little bit because we're
taping a lot of parodies and sketches i
need to get the creative mindset uh a
lot of they can do that
so that's what happened with the
recession i was like wait hold on a
second what do you mean who's saying
we're not in a recession they're saying
everybody so what do you mean everybody
said everybody in charge they're just
saying that we are not in a recession
but we are in a recession is it just is
it me or did you guys are you guys still
under the impression that we're in a
recession please you can comment below
it just helps again the algorithm but i
i think we're all on the same page
with the exception of this
administration in cnn yeah well like
when i bought ships ahoy because it has
my catchphrase on it yes i noticed that
they're half the size as they once were
because it's a save session or whatever
word they came up with
or not well chunks ahoy is now chips
ahoy and chips ahoy is nothing oh i see
yeah fair enough it's just a sugar
cookie
yeah
they just give you half food for more
money and they're like it's not a
recession right
that was like cadbury thins you guys
ever see you guys have cat like cadbury
in the united states oh yeah for sure
they did cadbury fins like it's a new
way to enjoy delectable chocolate with
half the guilt it's like they just give
you less chocolate yeah that's your
trick and now you're shaming me into
eating it you're like listen fatty
pretty soon you're just going to like
just smell the wrapper fattest that's
all you're getting
don't you remember it's just half the
chocolate there's no you're just giving
me half and charging me the same cadbury
thins okay
two of them no one's ever eaten a
cadbury egg on easter and been like i
feel so guilty yeah no exactly
no things i've done in my life this is
why jesus was resurrected so i could do
this okay bunny rabbit so
recession okay gas is obviously way up
uh consumer confidence you way down
everything is up inflation is up you
tried to buy beef lately
but come on man the economy is uh still
pretty it's pretty damn banging
according to former vice president biden
there's gonna be a lot of chatter today
on wall street and among pundits about
whether we are in a recession truth but
if you look at our job market consumer
spending
business investment we see signs of
economic progress in the second quarter
as well wrong
and yesterday's fed chairman
the fed chairman powell said made it
clear that he doesn't think the u.s
economy is currently in a recession
he said quote
there are too many areas of economic
where the economy is performing too well
he pointed to the labor market as an
example
okay
you know what you can comment where you
think the economy is performing well
aside from the stock market and talk
about a disconnect uh the labor market
sucks a lot of people are working
part-time jobs a lot of people can't
find skilled labor to fill the positions
but this is really this is this whole
story okay is about you and the fact
that you oh i'm looking at everyone here
but specifically you watching listening
you're a [ __ ] what did you think two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth meant an economy was in a
recession you idiot
where were you going by definitions and
[ __ ]
yeah actually yes
technically oxford languages defines it
as a period of temporary economic
decline during which trade and
industrial activity are reduced and then
specifically generally identified by a
fall
in gdp
in two successive quarters okay well
hold on a second maybe the left the
democrats can explain this so let's go
to what they are saying right now they
are setting the record straight you
[ __ ] we are not in a recession now and
um i i would you know
that we should be um not not
characterizing that as a result i
understand that but you're splitting
hairs i mean if the technical definition
is two quarters of contraction you're
saying that's not a recession that's not
to take
no that's not the technical definition
if things are going so great though then
why is it the white house officials are
trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession if we all understand a
recession to be two consecutive quarters
of negative gdp growth in a row and then
you have white house officials come up
here to say no no that's not what a
recession is it's something else how is
that not redefining recession because
that's not the definition many of you
have uh reported on
um
as secretary ellen
for the record uh two negative quarters
of gdp growth is not uh the technical
definition of recession it's not the
definition that economists have
traditionally uh relied on
okay
so that was uh biden's economic adviser
brian deese he just said just to be
clear that is not the technical
definition so we could be wrong here
okay because i was going by the literal
definition
but he is making clear that it is not
the technical definition right brian d's
biden's economic advisor as we say now
let's go back to then in 2008 hoping our
delorean diese
said this exactly i quote economists
have a technical definition of recession
which is two consecutive quarters
of negative growth uh hold on wait well
i'm just what did he just say now that
was then what's now two negative
quarters of gdp growth is
not uh the technical definition of
recession it's not the definition that
economists have traditionally uh relied
on
but hold on but then but then i have in
2008 this quote economists have a
technical definition of recession which
is two consecutive quarters of negative
growth that's him
same guy what's now
uh i guess what he just said what he
just said now two negative quarters of
gdp growth is
not uh the technical definition of
recession hold on a second hold on a
second stop stop when is then now
and now then
let's in the last 14 years they've
decided it's three okay
yeah three yeah yeah i guess the answer
is you're a [ __ ] right yes you are all
idiots just trust the experts when the
experts are completely inc always says
it's not the technical definition no
it's the literal definition and it was
your technical definition by ex
economists have a technical definition
of recession which is two consecutive
quarters of negative growth it could not
be more clear and here's the thing
people say well someone's likely to
change their mind
how do you change your mind on the
technical definition and literal
definition of something when it's always
been that you didn't change your mind
you're just lying yeah you know in the
staff meeting he's like you want me to
go out and say what
you saw him pause in the beginning he
goes and that's not the uh
technical definition there's someone
under that podium with a hot poker like
police academy just wow just a picture
of his family
uh okay the opposite of everything i've
ever said right he's like did i delete
that tweet
they don't buy this i'm just going to
pablo escobar's family more like geese
because he's full of poop
thank you
take that one
yeah
right on the old beak
all right let's go back to then
here's what professional uh pimp in
chief bill clinton had to say in the
year 2000
well a recession is two quarters in a
row of negative jokes i don't think
we're gonna have that
[ __ ]
clinton he murdered a guy
[Laughter]
so let me just here's one thing i just
want to be clear here you don't have to
take my word for this you know levar
burton i'll have a six-year-old come out
and read a pop out thank you you can go
to light of credit.com we always have
the references publicly available it's
not just these it's not just clinton
this was the accepted definition of
recession
for
always up until last week just to be
clear and what they want this is
gaslighting of the american people and
not just the american people by the way
you need to understand that business
owners and you know this uh gerald and
so do i as a small business owner we
rely on these metrics and these
definitions to anticipate when we need
to invest when we need to pull back when
we need to save money when we do it when
we need to maybe take on some more
inventory when we need to prepare for
lean time so if we're looking at a
recession
we need to know we need to know what
this is and they want to gas gaslight
not only you paying more at the pump
paying more at the grocery store but
business owners who are saying ah hold
on a second i think we're in a recession
they're saying no no no no don't believe
the mom-and-pop businesses why by the
way while they hand our tax dollars over
to big corporations let's be clear about
that the green energy displacement of
money also the displacement of money to
big oil companies from small oil
companies that's another thing that a
lot of people haven't really been aware
of and we'll cover soon here on this
show this is a gas lighting and a
displacement they don't want you to
believe
in yourself they don't want you to
believe your lion eyes and your lion
ears according to their own definitions
yeah and it was really funny to watch
them right before this report came out
they were everywhere saying that a
recession is not defined by negative gdp
growth look at our job market look at
this look at that every single show had
that and you remember what they got onto
donald trump for during kovid saying
that he wasn't being honest with the
american people about the the threat
that we were facing i understand that he
was trying to be like hey don't shut the
world down this is going to be really
bad if you do that right economically
right now they should come out and say
hey guys we have negative growth for two
quarters historically that's what this
has meant but and then consumer
confidence is fine
right we have a strong job market we
have a ton of other great things going
on if you want to keep the american
people spending money just do that right
now you look like a clown yeah well they
also don't have a good job market well
no that's what they should say if they
think it right right that's that's how
they should lie effectively this is more
effective yes right if i could let you
find a point look gerald advising people
on how to lie i like it no longer a boy
scout
well you do over the break
i left the state i went to dangerous
places
by that he means to his mother-in-law's
she lives in state oh well i apologize
you went to dave and buster yes i went
to new orleans dave and he played the
digital [ __ ] broke game only for two
days i thought i said that's two dead
people in that first i was gonna say
that's honestly that's long enough it
really was i jaded now oh no you you
didn't think you saw you did see you
didn't i don't know one of them was gone
well i guess they could have picked them
up yeah that's true no no they're not
that quick at picking them up they
pretty much just pretty much just let
nature take its course
in a garbage can though they bring in
three voodoo doctors and if that doesn't
work they put them in an ambulance right
and by ambulance we mean in the back of
a herald and mod hearse yeah a chicken
coop uh all right so let's let's give
you some more numbers for for so that it
doesn't exist just out there in the
ether right so you have some context so
according to dc clinton right in the
dictionary the united states is in a
recession why q1 was negative 1.6 we
were talking about gdp growth net
negative 1.6 q2 negative nine percent
now negative point nine percent sorry
negative point nine negative one point
six q one negative point nine q two
let's compare that to evil horrible mean
tweeter donald trump at this same point
in his presidency q1 was plus 3.8 and q2
was plus 2.7 which is
boy it's times like these that i
remember people's two biggest fears are
public speaking and cancer what made you
think of that kurd earth
why couldn't these boys have picked
cancer i don't know how he wanted to
stop that balcony that was a bad
terrible is there's still time left in
the show how is that a good thing well
one of them could still find a lump next
to their testicles
oh my god all right seriously i don't
know why we
said we made some studio changes i don't
know why we installed it was on the list
and gave them season tickets yeah it's
unbelievable it's just a colossal waste
of money it really is i thought it was
good at the time yeah i did too it was a
bogo
now on top of the figures that we have
uh the federal reserve increased
interest rates of course by 0.75 uh
basis points for the second time
in two months the second time in two
months which i know there's there's
there's good and bad to that because we
do understand an artificially sort of
manipulated economy when we were looking
at lending rates for a long time and how
that affected the housing market but
still this happening in only a couple of
months
i wonder i do wonder and i would like to
make a prediction as to what this likely
means for the economy
[Music]
call me to the mat on it if i'm wrong
[Laughter]
by the way that film did anyone ever
find it really messed up that she was
sleeping with a child i guess
the whole time and even when she turns
back into which she turns back into a
child tom hanks in the big clothes she's
not like i can't believe it she's like
yeah i did it with that kid yeah she's
like oh i'm gonna miss you yeah i liked
that you had a soda machine in bunk beds
yes
and a trampoline in an upper west side
loft
some weird at all
plus i had lots of sex with him yes
that's that too that young man no big
deal no one knew how to play piano at
fao schwartz like he did well there's no
better way to get a job as the assistant
to a ceo and no better way to get down
that vp ladies pants the boy john hurd
was pissed you guys can comment was it
just me when i go back and watch big the
first time i watched it i didn't really
think about it the second time i watched
it once i got to that scene i was like
ah wait yeah
ah there's a lot of those movies where
you're like this shouldn't have happened
no this shouldn't have happened but they
were normalizing it yeah they were
completely normalized of course now
would just be a lot of guys going up to
that machine going i wish i was young
yes exactly horrible or more so i wish
uh
he was young
come on over to my beach house
i'm about to be out of a new york subway
same thing here's the thing we all know
what's happening with the economy you
know what you are experiencing and this
is a big this is a big disconnect too
this is what happened under the years of
donald trump and you were seeing it with
donald trump right the media said
everything is terrible everything is
awful this country is is in its worst
state that we have ever seen in our
lifetime you heard reiner say that you
heard bette midler say that you would
hear cher say that all the people that
gay folks like they would say we are in
our worst state of affairs in my
lifetime but most americans thought
actually the economy is pretty good
actually our world standing is pretty
good we're not at war with anybody many
americans who didn't even like donald
trump had to acknowledge the contrast
after eight years of obama and now we
have another three years of joe biden
and you look at the rcp average his
polling is not going well and so what do
they need they need to
remove voices of dissent we've seen
people who have pointed out that the
recession definition definition has
changed their instagram posts now are
labeled misinformation you have to go
through a filter to get to it so you
have to remove your access to
information they have to redefine words
and then tell you don't believe your
line eyes and ears there's such a
disconnect there's a value to that i
know when everyone else laments everyone
else laments that oh we're more divided
than ever we may not come back we
shouldn't be coming back from this
why would we want to go back to living
under the cloud of a lie
having the scales removed from our from
our eyes is a good thing this is a good
thing it's painful but it's been a
necessary ripping off of the band-aid i
am never going to feign some kind of
unity or common ground with people who
hate everything that we stand for we
know what's going on with the economy
they want you to think that you're
simply crazy and not the people who want
to chop off their penises and suture up
their vaginas so don't worry former vice
president joe biden is telling you that
as it relates to the economy
everything's stellar
that doesn't sound like a recession to
me thank you very much mr president
how confident are you that we're not
heading towards a good recession
that was his good leaving one-liner that
doesn't sound like a recession to me
i love how he ran for the door yeah
fairness you can't hear anybody no no
there's people
that's just what happened is he goes out
he's ready to take questions but they
just
turn his hearing aid down and not
telling that he saw a dancing hot dog
from the movie theater and wanted to go
chase it yes
is there a girl over here i can smell
yes that's what they do is they lure her
like when they you know have a little
rattle with babies taking pictures they
just have a little six-year-old girl
like hey
hey it's a cabbage patch
like yogi bear to a pie
i love that like trump was transparent
to a fault when they asked questions
right and now he just ignores them right
and it's like this was the guy you
wanted great glad you won
enjoy your not a recession because he
said so you would not have been able to
hold trump back from answering questions
no that's what i mean and he would
immediately go to the people he hates
most right and then if it was a bad
question of them fake news right now you
you're terrible all right it's time to
take questions to
fat [ __ ] yeah yeah come on let's try it
what no economy is great anything else
we're not losing any points in the
economy you need to lose
you sound like some points
character from walmart i can't do trump
for some reason it's funnier in my head
though with your mustache
[Laughter]
that's all i got
i like it oh it just grew i like this
dash so look we're going to move on from
this to talk about uh also a free speech
issue which a lot of you don't
appreciate that it only exists here in
the united states for that it's a live
show monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern speaking of free speech we have
no idea how long we'll be on youtube
so you can watch us on rumble if you
don't want to watch on youtube monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern or you
can watch on mug club the podcast on
audio apple spotify all of that and with
parity week spotify will have uh the
album of all our priorities i think it's
like 20 now we've done so many of them
people have said can we get a
compilation somewhere so yes okay
there's a lot we'll figure that out but
we have no idea how long we'll be here
on youtube because you know
misinformation right now we just told
you that we're in a recession
that's not what wikipedia says
is it not did wikipedia change it well
they did they also changed the
definition of uh man well yeah
yeah the the head and gender yeah
well gender is a social construct that's
true they change the definition of vex
that's right
vaccine that's a big one
that's called a college try yes
[Laughter]
kind of like the vaccine
joe biden just he's been his blood type
is vaccine
gotten covered three times
there's nothing you can do
i'm better oh i'm sick
90 year old man with dementia
19 boosters they're like oh yeah i don't
know how it keeps coming back hey that's
another one remember when uh donald
trump got coveted and after three after
four days he came back and they're
saying there's no way he was lying the
media was a conspiracy he said he's
lying there's no way he got covered and
recovered so quickly the same thing
happened with joe biden and now he
tested positive again like oh these are
probably mild symptoms and rebound
remember they said there's no way that
donald trump could have recovered so
quickly right because they wanted all of
you to believe that you were going to
die due to the cough yeah and then he
was irresponsible for coming back to
work right remember he was going to
infect all of the staff i can't believe
it they have families too guys you know
that couple well and didn't he take like
a z pack zinc and like
that was this
he had some stuff no he had he had i
think he had prednisone and i think he
did i think he did the monoclonal
antibodies which don't really
i'm not a doctor we've talked about this
so before we've had doctors on the show
what i take is uh zinc quercetin and the
x clear the nasal spray so it reduces it
kind of and i look tested positive uh uh
yesterday then tested negative i feel a
lot better today had one day of it if i
had the covet which is as quick as
anything i've ever had i don't know
about you but if i have a flu or a bad
cold it lasts for a week
my son is uh well he was six when he got
covered for the second time and didn't
have any symptoms yeah and it was also
the week he was supposed to go to disney
world try telling a kid he's sick and
can't go to disney world when he feels
nothing he's probably sneezed right in
your face dude he's such a sweet kid and
out of nowhere he's like that is
[ __ ]
he's like you call that doctor back
right now
did he hit you in the face with a book i
was afraid of him for a day i'm like i
gotta lock the door and i sleep
wakes up tied to the bed like misery
yeah almost done
he's got a mickey mouse mallet
i'm rooting toodling going to disney
world
[Laughter]
all right so here's something else too
look i've talked about i think that the
most important issues are yes the
economy is important what's more
important than the economy is the fact
that this administration is lying about
the economy and the media is largely
carrying their water more important to
me than issues of taxes and they are
important are issues of your ability to
speak freely particularly in this new
landscape of social media new media
right the new town square
i think the idea of male female roles in
society if that goes away i think our
society goes away so sometimes people
say why do you talk about the cultural i
think that they are more important than
the marginal tax rates just to be clear
so i i believe that all of it needs to
be addressed but if you notice we focus
more on how the media is handling how
the media is responding to these lies
what the media relationship is with this
administration and it paints a very
terrifying picture so let's go now to
our
friends over there in the uk across the
pond and by friends i mean enemies
uh
and
i don't know if you know this if you've
watched to change my minds
you know that freedom of speech doesn't
exist anywhere outside of the united
states right comment below if you didn't
know that if you think it exists
anywhere outside of the united states
meaning absolute
outside of committing a crime
show me a country where it actually
exists that way where there is a
complete safeguard against the
government infringing upon it whatsoever
it does and it's enshrined into your
constitutional rights meaning the
government does not grant them the
government recognizes them find me one
other example
by the literal definition and then one
other find me an example in practice you
can't find either so let's go to the uk
so you guys see what's going on harry
miller he's a 51 year old veteran of the
british army uh he was arrested and this
isn't the first time but it is an
alarming story
arrested for sharing a meme
here's footage from the actual arrest
no
just which hampshire police would
realize how ridiculous this is
what what did it need to come to you
to this level because i don't understand
i posted something that he posted you
come to arrest me you don't arrest him
why has it come to this why am i in
cuffs because there's something
he shared then i shared because someone
has been caused obviously anxiety
based upon your
social media
okay hold on a second a few issues here
first off those cops are totalitarian
[ __ ] just to be clear
they are the start of the gestapo was it
called the milgram experiments can
someone bring it up it was some
something milligram midigram experiments
where they they had someone who was uh
they would have a subject who was
allowed to electroshock another subject
who was in on it to see if they would
actually just sort of carry out the
orders of authority and the results were
shocking
um
if you think it can't happen here of
course it can happen here those cops
should defy those orders before they
even leave the station
now his explanation is even worse well
it shouldn't escalate to this level but
you you obviously your post caused
anxiety dell not a second did you hear
the words coming out of your fascist
little prick mouth
your actions caused someone anxiety and
you think that that gives you the
authority to arrest somebody now let's
combine that it was the milgram
experiment that's right let's combine
that with the fact that with trans
lgbtq aip plus and generation z
everything causes them anxiety that's
true
well so being surrounded in four cops uh
little anxiety yeah i would think so
that causes a little bit of a stress
even if they're silly and they're uh
very very weak yes yeah by the way that
that's what it actually looks like to be
in cuffs not aoc walking with their
hands behind her back i just love that
fake arrest just hoping it could be a
real arrest
oh i hope it is a real arrest soon watch
your head oh no now your other eyes
googly so harry miller now they match
was arrested uh july 9 july 29th for
retweeting an image of four pride flags
arranged to look like a swastika look i
can show this because i live in the only
country that doesn't suck
and i don't i don't say that facetiously
it's the only country that doesn't suck
because it's the only country where i
can post that and not be afraid of
repercussions at least at this point
maybe youtube might decide that they
don't want it and we'll get to in a
second i've done this exact comparison
on our website i believe in 2015 and it
ended up being reposted in 2018 so we
have a direct ab comparison
this is the only country where you can
do it that man was arrested for
something that offended people he didn't
even he wasn't even the original creator
of the post by the way this guy named
lawrence fox yeah twitter june 27th yeah
so lawrence his his post was actually
making fun of how they enforce this
month on everybody saying that you have
to love it it's like it's like a fascist
enforcement you will celebrate this you
will love it everybody will say this is
wonderful and so in his tweet he said oh
holy and wonderful month i can't read it
it's up at the top there something like
that right so he's making fun of them
forcing you to think that this is a
wonderful month that everybody has to
just be in line with right and then
because he posted they go and arrest
somebody for posting it again you just
proved his point it just it just shows
what he meant they they can find a
reason to arrest anybody yeah you don't
promote
or celebrate anything you don't want to
and the weirdest part about that picture
is it's not i mean it is a photoshop but
it's also not it's just four of the
flags laid in a position it's more of a
centerpiece yeah
you're acting like nazis oh by the way
when you arrested that guy because you
don't like our post that's what the
nazis did right also if you're a fan of
this show and you're gay and you happen
to see that please arrange everything at
your wedding to look like that yes
please
just for fun
please stupid and make the uh the
complimentary name tags armbands yeah
just be like what i i guess i've never
heard of this what happened what's
what's going on just play just play
completely ignorant like i don't know
well we already paid for the corsages
hugo boss sponsored our wedding what
yeah what that's great yeah we were
going to write off in a mercedes limo
and shoot a walther so
let me give you some responses here from
the government in the uk carolyn russell
or caroline russell don't know don't
care a green party uh representative
she's a london assembly member condemned
the post and wrote this on twitter as a
london assembly member and a member of
the police and crime committee i hope
the met police will look into lawrence
fox using pride flags to create nazi
imagery and posting the images on a
public platform this is a hate crime oh
go back to one of the first changed my
minds that i did in 2015
hate speech isn't real
because of this
a crime doesn't need a foot murder it's
not a hate murder it's murder doesn't
need a footnote the whole reason for
calling something a hate crime or
starting with hate speech is to simply
give the government more authority to
label speech to be a crime and they've
tried this here in the united states
they tried it with us right hirono i
think pelosi these people they were they
were forced to ask susan wijitz get the
recode conference after the vox
apocalypse forced to ask her well why is
stevenson in the platform she said well
crowder didn't actually violate any of
our rules so they created a new one
sorry for the rest of you on youtube for
that whole borderline content stuff we
didn't mean for that to happen now are
bad
the reported offense falls under what
they call the malicious communications
act this was passed by parliament 1988
amended in 2001 to include internet
communications just so you know this is
the policy this is the law i'm going to
read it the references are available at
loudouncar.com if you want to read the
entire thing says any person who sends
to another person any article or
electronic communication which is of an
indecent or grossly offensive nature is
guilty of an offense if his purpose or
one of his purposes in sending it is
that it should cause distress or anxiety
to the recipient or to any other person
to whom he intends that it or its
contents or nature should be
communicated how about
you uk how about that where's john
oliver talking about that you know he
always wants to talk about what's wrong
here in the united states right where is
he mr comedian taking his government to
task for silencing people
for opinions and by the way not even all
that offensive it's a meme
has anybody there ever instagram some of
their food
that's offensive to me i don't really
think i mean have you seen english food
it's
you had your up oh what people do look
at my bangers in mash fish and chips
look at more haggis there are starving
kids in africa like keep it yes
i'll take relief rice yes no thank you
i'm going to go eat another sand bowl
yes i'll just lick the fry it flies off
my face like frogs yes you enjoy your
fried card and liver
it's like a cucumber sandwich i would
like you to never speak to me right yes
exactly
but but we put the cucumber on this on
the slice
and then we call it a sandwich it's not
a sandwich though no it is to me you're
an inferior country we know
we know this is why we left you it's why
our teeth are like this they're making
it because it doesn't want the food
that's right we're trying to fall out
it's actually a part of our evolution
since everything we have is boiled or
broiled or broiled and boiled we don't
need our teeth anymore for chewing it's
more of just sort of a gumming yes we
don't we don't care for it we don't
say no it's all mush
so
lawrence responded to the assembly
member russell the green party member
saying this is the uk not china good to
know you would like to see your
political opponents prosecuted for hate
locked up and probably worse so thanks
for proving my point here here's the
thing
i would like to support lawrence
fox and i do support him in principle
but legally he doesn't have a leg to
stand on because guess what the uk is
like china in that sense you know what
you know you know where else is like
china australia and canada
pretty much everywhere that's not the
united states you might find some
norwegian countries who kind of
idealize freedom of speech but they
don't really have it constitutionally
enshrined but a lot of people in the uk
actually think they have the right to
speak freely so did canadians until
their accounts were frozen for
organizing a legal peaceful protest
remember those truckers oh yeah
absolutely no until mike ward made a
joke yep no that's a perfect example in
in canada mike ward made a joke i think
we actually have that as an example yeah
overlay uh j4 the mike ward case our
friend uh he made a joke and he was
forced before human rights tribunal lost
had to go to the supreme court and it
wasn't even a racist or sexist joke we
have other examples here uh england
there's a guy named simon leger he was
arrested for singing kung fu fighting
doing that at a karaoke bar in australia
zoe lee buehler we talked about her
arrested for an anti-lockdown facebook
post
this is the kind of stuff that happens
across the globe on a regular basis
outside of the united states and you
have to
you have to put it this way when people
say oh the left and the right and i take
it on an issue by issue basis look
believe me we call republicans to the
mat when they are phonies and they
absolutely deserve to be yeah
but if you value freedom of speech
what's you are precluded
precluded from voting for the democrat
party today you absolutely positively
cannot if the democrats had their way
and what do i mean by that let's go down
the list let's go down the list just for
people in line for the presidency you
would have former vice president joe
biden president kamala harris you would
have i believe nancy pelosi would be
number three uh president pro-temporam
would be number four i'm trying to
remember the name there anyway if the
right amount of planes go down because
they happen to be flying over taiwan
with an escort
you might end up with someone someone
else but let's go through every single
one of one of them elizabeth warren look
at it look at anyone aoc the squad yeah
they all want your speech regularly none
of them support freedom of speech they
all believe that big tech should have
more power they if they had their way
completely unfettered if there were no
republicans if there were no
conservatives standing in their way it
would be just like australia it would be
just like canada it would be just like
the uk that's what they want they
consistently tell you
we need to be more like these european
countries that's the big divide i think
we're better than europe that's why we
left i think europe sucks yeah and every
time they give a speech to their
supporters about speech that should not
be allowed they do it to thunderous
applause right people are going right
along with this not realizing what
they're doing no well because they don't
want to seem like somebody who's hateful
but
where are the examples of actual hate
that's the part that scares me so much
about this going on in other countries
you're talking about somebody who's
anti-lockdown being arrested
there's never any real example that
shows any sort of like bigotry
or anything that you could even would be
even considered questionable right
or you know it's considered hateful to
say that hey you guys redefined
recession
yeah hey lock them up
but it feels like one you know on
account of the 17 gas prices right the
food's getting smaller stop the hate
speech hey we don't allow hate speech on
this show it's unbelievable it's a it's
a what what's the cute word they used
for it too a short session they came up
with a short session yeah some stupid
word it's just a small pinch yeah yeah
well what we give you less stuff for
more money yeah what do you want your
reception what are you talking about you
haven't heard about the buy one get one
more expensive deal i don't understand
what are you complaining about there's
no jobs for you to pay for it yeah it's
the beauray buy one get you buy one you
get raped there's by the way this is
exactly
it's exactly like when we did this over
at louderwithcrowder.com uh this this
meme right here you can bring it up of
the gestapo this was during the gay
wedding cake issue and it was uh nine
you will assign our marriage licenses uv
to bake our cakes it was just a meme we
did it we referred to them as the
gestapo at that point because businesses
should have the right to do whatever
they want to do right
it's the exact same guess what no one
came banging down my door i wasn't
arrested but if the left had its way i
would have been and i know right now if
the left would have its way they're
happy at that right now they'll go i
think you should get arrested
give it a shot
i'd say every wedding cake's pretty gay
it's true
they also taste like crap ours was good
very tasty no it wasn't up i was at your
wedding yeah and you skipped the cake no
i tried the cake i skipped it after one
bite
yeah he probably went up and he was like
this is delicious where's the trash yeah
exactly
watching my figure
the compost bin
we had great cake all right let's move
on to this so now we have freedom of
speech we've gone through the in freedom
of speech by the way this is why it's so
important so that we can tell you about
the definition of a recession if they
remove your ability to speak because you
say i don't want to celebrate the gay
pride month then we'll guess what no one
can say hold on a second reese you were
just saying rhys or breese the guy's
name before
the economist you were just saying the
technical definition
that guy
that's not a talk talk to me prick so
yeah yeah let's go goose and hope it's
nothing like top gun yes exactly
you with the mustache you have the goose
stash right now yeah i do yeah yeah
if you can't speak out about the same
the the the i want to say same-sex the
gay pride month the lgbtqa by the way i
haven't even seen gay guys at the gay
pride month i've just seen a bunch of
drag queens and angry fat lesbians with
shirts from bass pro so i'm sorry gay
guys you're yesterday's news the
movement has been hijacked yeah you are
posse
i think that they just made a bunch of
like rainbow robin williams suspenders
in the 70s they thought would take off
and didn't and we're just still selling
those yeah exactly
and then gallagher bought the surplus
yeah so i'll take half of these half of
these and a giant couch smash and 400
000 bowling pins that are gigantic yes
he also owns crazy amount of patents he
does yeah gallagher he's an insane
person all right well then nobody buys
off of him which is why he's broke but
let's move on to this because we
wouldn't be allowed to discuss this in
the uk so here in the united states we
can take a steaming uh
self-relieving
exercise all over it uh drag everything
right now is permeating everything in
america and it's a horrible thing now i
remember when transvestites used to be
the hoovers of the world in the head of
the fbi people who just you know they
sort of did it for fun maybe bob hope
did it a uso tour uh then they had
transsexuals which were very rare
few and far between oh no you're saying
then because but that's okay
wrong then cool man heard me say the
word family's like i need to hit him
he's queued up for it baby i gotta tell
you it worked it worked back then it was
transvestites and transsexuals when they
said transgender they go what makes
transgender someone who thinks they're a
woman okay so do they have to do the
bottom half no that's a transsexual do
they have to do they have to do the
breast no that's the transsexual do that
through the hormone replacement there he
knows the transsexual so what's a
transgender transvestite who just says
he really really is a woman
okay
and so i remember when drag queen just
meant gay guys who dressed up like women
right uh but now it's spread beyond gay
bars
uh and uh of course the appropriate
public schools to go on to ruin even
more of america so now let's go to then
this was back uh in april uh and uh this
is making the rounds on social media uh
an episcopal school
and by an episcopal meeting it's not a
thing invited a drag queen to perform
and i warn you if you have children you
probably don't want them watching this
unlike the kids who were present
uh roll the cliff
get all the masks
telling them to stand up stand up
he's so funny watch this watch the turn
you don't get that fat on communion
wafers
that would not be allowed in any church
no
she just burst into flames
it starts melting like she he looked at
the ark of the covenant z
[Applause]
where are the nuns where are the nuns
with the ruler making you get on your
knees to make sure the skirt you know
goes beyond your dick
that wouldn't even be acceptable for a
sister no
if a guy or a girl walked into church
that way they would be asked to leave to
put something else on they probably
would be nice about it but nobody is
going to allow you to walk down the
center aisle with kids in attendance
showing you're not nobody long the
episcopalians will
they're the acceptable and by the way on
his tick tock the drag queen
brita filter more like more like carbon
block yes more like inactivated charcoal
i like coffee mate yes
creamer no hold on it's the berta filter
the the rita slash filter x-lax
gosh
i cannot breed a filter
people have to take this seriously think
about this you have to take it seriously
yes we uh feel honored we are honored to
be represented by um
brita filter and uh trojan mccondom face
thank you very much i thought we got
that wrong
because i couldn't believe it we also
have a magnum you're going to want to uh
turn around yeah yeah that's uh that's
weird and next up we will be of course
entertained by snap crackle pop all one
person yes and uh someone who goes
cuckoo for [ __ ]
coco no they just wow that one was not
even really a pun
well you know what they're all welcome
here at the episcopalian congregation
you're welcome to pray please go to our
nursery
unattended unmonitored now kids this is
what will be in hell yes
well if we believed in hell but we're
episcopalian we don't really believe
anything no oh we're allowing this to
happen
at least get a hot one
good luck
so that performer you just saw brita
filter
jeez uh wrote on the tick tock i
literally went to church to teach the
children today
a catholic high school here in nyc
invited me to their pride chapel i think
that i don't think peter filter did the
right research i believe it's
episcopalian for sure what are you gonna
teach them how to not
no yeah a catholic high school would
only have a shame chapel yeah
well i think you know what the shame
chapel isn't all wrong no i i'm going to
say they had it right yep
yeah i would say use the ruler on the
knuckles but
mr phil mr filter might like it yeah
i'm sorry ms filter i don't know i don't
know i'm not sure if she's married but
i'm not yeah
i didn't see a ring
i mean it saw a ring not my finger yeah
exactly those rings
brita filter also wrote visibility
matters and i'm so honored to
have had the chance to talk to you about
my work as an
lgbtq plus drag queen activist and hell
followed with it wow rapture so quickly
who knew
pestilence plagued by the way i went
onto their website for the great this is
the grace i forget the middle name of it
but grace episcopalian church right
um
they list they wanted to make sure they
said we want to have a diverse set of
students parents faculty
staff they listed that twice i'm not
sure why um and we don't have any place
for and they like racism sexism classism
and i'm like nodding my head in
agreement then it's like sexual
orientation you want to accept all of
those and you want to accept any uh
gender identity i'm like what i'm sorry
i thought this said church yeah yeah
like i didn't understand i thought the
everybody's opinion is fantastic in your
church except for
gods
well you know what though i think they
should they should have uh you know uh
toss uh me shack brita filter and bend
to go into the uh fiery furnace and see
what happens see if i don't know
and behold yesterday
and i know a drag queen walker
filter and see what good comes out
that's unbelievable they have a ph strip
they're still fluoride the hell that's
crazy who sends their kids to that
calling it a church
sick people i'm sorry sick people i'm
sorry sick people i wouldn't send my
kids to a normal strip club i wouldn't
send my kids to a school that let all of
their fellow actual female students
dress up like buffalo bill raggedy
anne's
well
i mean
dave's like some of us got lower stances
everybody's not perfect that's true no i
i
i just don't understand if you want to
go and worship in a place because you
believe in god and you have your own
issues fine i i get that but there's a
difference between that and letting them
a show well yeah but you can't change
like what like you can't look at the
book and go yeah i think all this is uh
good take out page 74. i don't like page
127 and oh i'm all about absolutely gone
let's go to page 142 just to pop out cod
piece
okay we're gonna get rid of that we just
got go do something else and call it
something else but it is not worshipping
god when you say all these things are
just fine your bibles sit down with
centers and say you're cool he said you
got to change your ways guys sorry
bibles are six pages yeah most of those
garth brooks lyrics yeah it's just that
when five are just the green new deal
and
low aoc hey look churches every
we people want to want to talk about
what can you do well not just
politically get involved
this is okay
this is the fault i will tell you this
of feminist women and women watching
right now you need to start cleaning
your own ranks you need to start
fighting i got into a conversation with
a woman at the gym not too long ago
about this during the break there were
three guys there and there were two
women
and there was what do we do right now
with like you know these transgender
athletes this was someone who played
volleyball competing in women's sports i
said
you
you need to fight your friends because
men have overwhelmingly opposed this for
a long time when we're talking about
sports specifically i'll bring it back
to drag queens and church unless you
literally signed up for it right and
then women overwhelmingly supported it
and she goes well that's not me i said
that's what you need to change guess
what statistically it's been largely
white women not black women not latino
women largely white suburban women who
have supported this transgender movement
to be nice guess what men don't do it's
if you were to say you know
statistically men actually have a
problem with insert xy we would go man
we better get a handle on this and i
said to her you need to start
fighting
right now if you don't want to lose this
she said well what am i you know i want
to have i don't want to alienate my
friends i said it doesn't matter we do
it all the time do you realize what i
would have said if gerald or dave said
i'm having a baby what the hell is wrong
with you
right away if they saw the way men treat
each other we call each other to the mat
on a regular basis women are afraid to
and so they don't realize that
70-something percent of women in their
ranks support this crap she said well
most of my friends are conservative and
so i don't really talk about these
things with my liberal friends i said
call up someone you hate
and argue with them she's am i just
supposed to start a fight at the she
said this am i supposed to start a fight
at the pta conference i said yes
yes that is exactly right
fight every single inch women you
disproportionately are in positions of
uh board members and churches a lot of
people think because mo the pastors are
largely men the truth is the church is
right now if you look at people in
positions of authority largely board
members people are involved with running
small groups mostly women
you need to start fighting this [ __ ]
this is affecting you and it's largely
affecting your daughters we kind of have
a self-defeating mechanism here with men
notice there aren't a lot of women going
into men's sports dominating female to
male transgenders notice they're not
really happening in all male spaces and
it being a problem because they kind of
get drummed out of the core and men
don't really include people who aren't
amongst them as amongst them doesn't
mean you're rude to them but it's pretty
easy to tell
women this is incumbent upon you it is
entirely because of the feminist
movement trying to eliminate the lines
between male and female men and women
women can do everything men can do which
is not true
women can do everything men can do women
don't need a man to raise children none
of those things are true but it makes
way for the lie
where we are that men and women are a
figment of your imagination this is all
a byproduct of feminism i know what
you're saying i'm not a feminist doesn't
matter
a lot of your friends are you need to
fight them every single step of the way
so that your demographics don't change
the way that male demographics haven't
changed to that degree generation z's
and exceptions lots of [ __ ] boys now
well it's true though but you're right
because if if you really do believe in
it and you want to fight against it the
greatest way to lose is is a white flag
never saying anything you've already
given up when the other side's willing
to fight which means this will continue
to happen and you will lose and the
fight will come to you it'll just be at
a point where you can't win anymore
absolutely it's going to happen one way
or the other let's just do it now when
you can actually have a civil
conversation with most people who just
don't have really much of an opinion on
this and go oh i never knew that it's
the laziest argument people say oh it
doesn't affect you you're right it
doesn't affect me because i'm not in the
ncaa swimming you're right it doesn't
affect me because i don't compete in mma
and risk being concussed by a man now
living as a woman you're right it
doesn't affect me because i would never
set foot in the silly episcopalian
church i could say that about all those
things and they use this same argument
oh what are you mad it doesn't affect
you a mask well guess what it actually
does when you say that i don't have
inalienable rights
that affects everybody when the
government says we can lock you down
indefinitely that affects everybody when
you say well you know what actually
there's no difference between men and
women and the most important thing you
can do former vice president of the
united states joe biden said the most
important thing you can do is affirm
your child's gender oop just open the
door to child protective services taking
your kid away if you don't put them on
puberty blockers by the way the primary
hospital have performed these uh
pre-pubescent operations or
interventions in the uk just got shut
down oh we'll talk about that later this
week
you know
one of the beauties of life is actually
sunshine and nature and the farther we
get away from going outside and being
part of nature with the less natural
we're becoming well yeah i would love to
go out in nature unfortunately the drag
queens have rubbed their oily asses all
over every park well they're indoors
apparently rubbing their ass on every
pew that's the point nowhere nowhere is
untouched by the astroglide drag act
not even the subway well that was
already there like a dog with the carpet
only it's everything i haven't seen this
much semen in the subway since
every day every day oh boy
but now it's from now but now it's
ladies even so yes
let's go to uh now that was then now
joint base langley uh eustis in virginia
hosted a diversity equity and inclusion
summer festival i'm sorry so according
to the festival's eventcreate.com harpy
daniels
the navy drag queen
was one of the performances and by the
way i got in trouble for referring to i
believe it was aoc as a harpy it might
have been whitmer i might have said
floozy harlot i don't know the point is
they voluntarily took the name you're
saying that you're a [ __ ] drag queen
her brother sister does crazy cigar
tricks yes
don't get me started on the harmonica
so this is the navy drag queen say hello
by the way everybody to completely
normal what's wrong with you
harpy daniels
it's come to my attention that you don't
know who i am
oh
oh that's oh that's the that's the real
you sorry the real you after four hours
of henson prosthetics
they don't know the real me the real me
requires hundreds of dollars in makeup
and hair extensions but this is what i
am on the inside and just think of that
poor broad rachel dolezal and all the
crap we gave her [ __ ] he just put on a
weave
so harpy daniels that's petty officer
second class uh joshua kelly of the u.s
navy uh by the way also a member of
trans team six
just for those of you who didn't know
lots of training yes i went into that
remember kids knowing your pronouns is
half the battle
the other half is keeping up with your
uh volvoplasty aftercare make sure you
have your
expansion device fighting's nothing
anymore no
we gotta we gotta start in the army
national guard you're trans
we gotta go in there and fight
all right i need 38 hours to put my
makeup on yes if china is looking for
like a time like when do we invade uh
now i think is reasonable oh they could
have said that that video would have
been saying that for the last two years
yeah that's probably now i know what
you're saying this is one of those
things you're just going off half [ __ ]
you know the information but i want you
to be ready to hit the like button by
that i mean hit the like button right
now and leave your comment uh because
all references are available at
crowder.com we did our due diligence i
threw up in my mouth a little a
spokesman for the base verified that the
installation commander signed off on the
event and approved the use of
taxpayer-funded military resources
so not is this enough hey dave go back
to using cocaine does cocaine make you
funny couldn't hurt oh
cheryl
here
let your wife have some you could be the
next philharmonic all right that's
enough with those guys hopefully we can
just get rid of them at some point that
hurt i mean he hit me in the face so
this is my question to you before we go
here to uh play what are we playing
today uh token now and we're playing
what are we playing simple or not hate
symbol or not on mug club uh again keep
in mind that it is parody week last week
of august first week of september share
the show sharing is caring before we
leave dayton ohio is where dave is going
to be this weekend dayton ohio we'll
plug it more again on mug club uh my
final question to you is
what do you find
more aggravating
harpy daniels or the episcopalian church
but i kind of repeat myself that's the
same
who'd have thought that the national
guard would seem tougher than the navy
a navy seal yeah
those village people man they were posit
they were positively oracles oh they
were right well they were so much more
manly well hold on hold that thought
because i know dave is just just
desperately he's biting his lip because
he doesn't want to let's you know what
youtube we love you thank you so much
we'll be back tomorrow piss off